unser sohn war zum zeitpunkt des
absturzes nicht depressiv
[Musik]
wir müssen vielleicht glaube ich für
alle bei lufthansa fassungslos zur
kenntnis nehmen dass das flugzeug
offensichtlich will ich zum absturz
gebracht wurde
was liegt durch den co piloten des
fluges
[Musik]
da muss doch auffallen dass der mann
krank ist das kann doch nicht sein
wir können psychisch und sollten
psychisch kranke piloten nicht im
cockpit erst neutralisieren sondern wir
sollten sie vorher müssten mechanismen
gefunden und verbessert werden
das psychisch kranken piloten erst gar
nicht ins cockpit gelangen können
[Musik]
und die luft langsam muss dafür sorgen
dass so etwas nicht mehr passiert
[Musik]